hey  you okay there jesus  i think i hurt someone this is ed warren  here with lorraine all right let's get  started  presidents of brookfield were shocked  this afternoon by the broad daylight  murder of bruno sauls  the court accepts the existence of god  every time a witness swears to tell the  [Music]  truth  i think it's about time they accept the  existence of the devil  whatever is going on whatever happened  that day that was not ernie  it's a witch's totem we think your  family was  cursed and that connection is still open  i'm only interested in reality  but i can see things that your people  [Music]  can't  [Music]  something terrible happened here  the master satanist is not an adversary  to be taken lightly  you need to come back you're saving him  worth everything you have  because that's what an affair will cost  the raid  [Music]  you